why our city's full of uncomfortable
benches
this one has arm rests to prevent you
from dozing off
here's another again with the arms the
stiff metal and this one it's brand new
the MTA in New York City began
installing them as a part of a subway
enhancement plan and they don't call it
a bench they prefer the term leaning
bars so what if I told you it was
designed with discomfort in mind New
York City is filled with some of the
most innovative architecture and urban
planning in the world today nearly every
kind of public space here has been
developed with the close attention to
detail so these benches are no mistake
they're designed to allow you to sit but
not get too cozy and that's intentional
the concept stems from a school of
thought that goes by many names but
today we'll use defensive design
defensive design is about moderating
behavior the goal is to limit the ways
an object can be misused these benches
have arm rests because that will prevent
anyone from laying down their short back
is another nod to say this bench isn't
yours forever this trend is worldwide
and it's not just in the benches when
you start looking for defensive designs
in New York City you'll find examples
everywhere it's the presence of security
cameras and subway turnstiles or in
Times Square
it's these spikes on this column meant
to deter birds
it's the knobs on these ledges made to
discourage skateboarders and there were
once sprinklers underneath the awning of
this bookstore to prevent people from
sleeping manner
it's sidewalk barriers it's even these
regular streetlights yeah
street lights are probably some of the
most recognizable defensive designs when
they surfaced in 19th century Western
cities the dynamic of urban life changed
because of them more people spend more
time outside at night which drove
economic development and a reduction in
crime most hostile architecture tries to
influence behavior in a similar way the
designs attempt to make public space a
bit more hospitable more ideal defensive
designs can deter crime it can prevent
the destruction of public property and
it can prevent loitering but there is a
reason why defensive design is
characterized as hostile take the
example of the leaning bar disability
advocates have a problem with that
appearing in the MTA one advocate
pointed out that people who travel who
have disabilities or just get tired
sometimes need a bench to sit on and not
a wall to lean against and while no one
likes an uncomfortable bench
these additions mean something more for
people who are experiencing homelessness
the United States is currently
experiencing a decline in the overall
homeless population but in New York City
the number of homeless people is growing
about 1800 people were found to have
been sleeping in the subway that's
because emergency shelter isn't always a
viable option there are several examples
of hostile architecture that target
people who are homeless these designs
imply that public spaces not where
homeless people should be as it goes
city planners have a dilemma how do they
design inclusive cities as for the
enhanced subway initiative the mta's MOC
designs highlight new USB ports and
electronic signage and stations but you
won't find any press materials
highlighting this uncomfortable bench
excuse me the leaning bar that's because
it makes for an uncomfortable discussion
about who we design public space for and
who gets left out
[Music]